(Vidéo : Contrôleur aérien dirigeant le trafic)
C'est notre contrôleur aérien appelant
l'aéroport international de Kigali.
Et quand le Zip arrive à l'hôpital,
il descend à 9 mètres environ et laisse tomber le paquet.
On utilise un simple parachute en papier - pourquoi faire compliqué ? -
qui permet de déposer le paquet au sol de manière douce et fiable,
au même endroit à chaque fois.
Donc, c'est comme le covoiturage ;
les médecins reçoivent un SMS une minute avant notre arrivée, disant :
« Allez dehors et recevez votre livraison. »
(Rires)
Et puis --
(Applaudissements)
et puis les médecins ont ce dont ils ont besoin pour sauver la vie du patient.
Voici la livraison vue de notre centre de distribution ;
ce véhicule est à 50 kilomètres environ.
Nous pouvons regarder le véhicule quand il fait une livraison à l'hôpital
en temps réel.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué les plots
qui viennent de ce véhicule sur l'écran.
Ces plots sont des paquets de données
que nous recevons via les réseaux GSM.
Donc ces avions ont des cartes SIM tout comme votre portable,
et ils communiquent sur le réseau GSM
pour que nous puissions les contrôler tout le temps.
Croyez-le ou non, nous achetons un forfait familial,
(Rires)
pour cette flotte d'avions,
afin d'obtenir les meilleurs tarifs.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas une blague.
Donc aujourd'hui, nous fournissons environ 20%
du besoin national du Rwanda en sang,
en dehors de Kigali.
Nous desservons une douzaine d'hôpitaux,
et nous ajoutons des hôpitaux à ce réseau à un rythme accéléré.
Tous ces hôpitaux ne reçoivent du sang que de cette manière,
et la plupart de ces hôpitaux passent plusieurs commandes tous les jours.
Dans toute logistique de santé,
vous devez toujours choisir entre le gaspillages et l'accès.
Donc, si vous voulez éliminer le gaspillage, vous gardez tout centralisé.
Par conséquent, lorsque les patients ont des urgences,
ils n'auront pas parfois le produit médical dont ils ont besoin.
Si vous voulez optimiser l'accès, on garde les médicaments au dernier km,
dans les hôpitaux ou les centres.
Alors, les patients ont ce dont ils ont besoin.
Mais on finit par jeter beaucoup de médicament,
ce qui coûtera très cher.
Ce qui est incroyable, c'est que le gouvernement rwandais
a été capable de briser ce cycle de façon permanente.
Car les médecins peuvent obtenir ce dont ils ont besoin instantanément.
En fait, ils stockent moins de sang dans les hôpitaux.
Bien que l'utilisation de produits sanguins ait considérablement augmenté
dans les hôpitaux que nous desservons,
au cours des neuf derniers mois, aucune unité de sang n'a expiré
dans ces hôpitaux.
(Applaudissements)
C'est un résultat incroyable.
En fait, aucun autre système de santé n'a réussi à le faire
sur la planète,
et c'est arrivé ici.
Mais, quand on parle de livraison instantanée de produits médicaux,
la chose la plus importante, c'est les patients.
Laissez-moi vous donner un exemple.
Il y a quelques mois, une mère de 24 ans est arrivée dans l'un des hôpitaux
que nous desservons,
et elle a accouché par césarienne.
Mais cela a entraîné des complications, et elle a commencé à saigner.
Heureusement, les médecins avaient en main du sang de même type que le sien
qui avait été livré via le service de Zipline,
et ainsi ils l'ont transfusée avec quelques unités de sang.
Mais elle a consommé ces unités en dix minutes.
Dans ce cas, la vie de cette mère est en grave danger -
quel que soit l'hôpital, n'importe où dans monde.
Mais heureusement, les médecins qui s'occupaient d'elle,
ont directement appelé notre centre de distribution,
ils ont passé une commande d'urgence,
et notre équipe a fait des livraisons en urgence, les unes après les autres,
encore et encore.
Ils ont fini par envoyer 7 unités de globules rouges,
4 unités de plasma,
et 2 unités de plaquettes.
Une quantité de sang supérieure à celle qu'on a dans le corps.
Tout a été transfusé en elle,
les médecins ont pu la stabiliser,
et elle est aujourd'hui en bonne santé.
(Applaudissements)
Depuis notre démarrage, nous avons fait environ 400 livraisons d'urgence comme ça,
et c'est la même histoire derrière la plupart de ces urgences.
Voici quelques mamans
qui ont reçu des transfusions de cette manière
au cours des derniers mois.
Rappelez-vous : quand on aide un médecin à sauver la vie d'une mère,
ce n'est pas seulement sa vie qu'on sauve.
C'est aussi un petit garçon ou une petite fille,
qui aura une mère durant son enfance.
(Applaudissements)
Mais je veux être clair :
l'hémorragie à l'accouchement n'est pas un problème du Rwanda,
ni des pays en développement.
C'est un problème mondial.
La santé maternelle est un défi partout.
La principale différence est que le Rwanda a été le premier pays
qui a utilisé une technologie radicale pour faire quelque chose.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle cette attitude en Afrique, où on dit que
la technologie avancée ne marche pas ici
ou a besoin d'aide,
est totalement fausse.
L'Afrique peut représenter la rupture.
Ces économies en développement peuvent dépasser les grandes et les riches.
Et ils peuvent totalement sauter le pas avec l'absence d'infrastructure existante
pour aller vers des systèmes plus récents et meilleurs.
En 2000,
si vous aviez dit que des réseaux GSM de haute qualité allaient être déployés
dans toute l'Afrique,
les gens vous auraient dit que vous étiez fou.
Et pourtant, personne n'a anticipé
à quelle vitesse ces réseaux allaient connecter et aider les gens.
Aujourd'hui, 44% du PIB du Kenya passe par M-Pesa,
leur plateforme de paiement mobile.
Et pas que ça,
notre flotte autonome de véhicules s'appuie sur ce réseau cellulaire.
Au cours des années à venir, lorsque nous desservirons des centres de soins privés,
nous utiliserons aussi cette plateforme mobile
pour collecter les frais de livraison.
Donc, l'innovation mène à plus d'innovation qui mène à plus d'innovation.
Et pendant ce temps,
la plupart des gens qui vivent dans les économies développées,
pensent que la livraison basée sur les drones est technologiquement impossible,
encore moins à l'échelle nationale en Afrique de l'Est.
Et je veux bien dire l'Afrique de l'Est, pas seulement le Rwanda.
Jeudi, il y a quelques jours,
le ministère tanzanien de la Santé a annoncé
qu'il allait utiliser cette technologie
pour fournir des livraisons instantanées d'une large gamme de produits médicaux
à 10 millions des personnes, les plus difficiles à atteindre dans le pays.
(Applaudissements)
Ça sera en fait le plus grand système autonome dans le monde.
Pour vous donner une idée à quoi ceci ressemble,
voici l'un des premiers centres de distribution.
Vous pouvez voir autour de ce centre, dans un rayon de 75 Km,
les centaines de centres de santé et d'hôpitaux que nous desservirons,
tous ruraux,
à partir de ce centre de distribution.
Mais pour servir plus de 20% de la population de la Tanzanie,
on aura besoin de plusieurs centres de distribution.
On en aura besoin de quatre.
Et à partir de ces centres de distribution,
nous comptons faire plusieurs centaines de livraisons chaque jour,
et ce système va rendre service à plus de 1 000 établissements de santé
et hôpitaux dans le pays.
Alors oui, l'Afrique de l'Est évolue très vite.
Une chose que les gens oublient souvent, me semble-t-il,
c'est que ce genre de sauts génère des gains cumulatifs.
Par exemple, en investissant dans cette infrastructure de soins de santé,
le Rwanda dispose désormais d'un réseau logistique aérien qu'il peut utiliser
pour catalyser d'autres parties de son économie,
comme l'agriculture ou le e-commerce.
Plus important encore,
100% des équipes que nous engageons dans ces centres de distribution sont locales.
Alors, voici notre équipe rwandaise,
formée par un groupe d'ingénieurs et d'opérateurs extraordinaires.
Ils gèrent l'unique système de livraison automatisé dans le monde,
opérant à l'échelle nationale.
Ils ont été capables de maîtriser une chose
que les plus grandes entreprises technologiques du monde
n'ont pas encore réussi à comprendre.
Ils sont donc des vrais héros.
(Applaudissements)
Ce sont des vrais héros.
Notre équipe a pour mission de fournir un accès basique aux médicaments,
aux 7 milliards de personnes sur la planète,
quelle que soit la difficulté pour les atteindre.
On parle souvent aux gens de cette mission,
ils disent : « C'est très généreux de votre part, très philanthropique. »
Non !
La philanthropie n'a rien à voir là-dedans.
En raison des contrats commerciaux qu'on signe avec les ministères de santé,
ces réseaux sont 100% durables et évolutifs.
Et la raison pour laquelle on s'efforce de corriger cette perception erronée,
est que l'entrepreneuriat est la seule force de l'histoire
qui a sorti des millions des personnes de la pauvreté.
(Applaudissements)
Aucune aide étrangère ne peut durablement employer
250 millions de jeunes Africains.
Et les emplois que ces enfants ont pu avoir il y a 10 ans
sont presque automatisés,
ou en train d'être modifiés par la technologie.
Ils cherchent donc de nouvelles compétences,
de nouveaux avantages compétitifs.
Ils cherchent des start-ups.
Pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas plus de start-ups qui s'attaquent à ces problèmes mondiaux
rencontrés par des milliards personnes dans les économies en développement ?
C'est parce que les investisseurs et les entrepreneurs ne voient pas
cette opportunité.
Nous pensons que ces problèmes relèvent du domaine des ONG ou des gouvernements,
pas des entreprises privées.
C'est ce que nous devons changer.
Vous avez peut-être remarqué que j'ai laissé quelque chose
hors de la vidéo que j'ai montrée.
Je ne vous ai pas montré l'atterrissage
quand les avions reviennent au centre de distribution.
Donc, cela peut vous sembler évident :
aucun avion n'a de train d'atterrissage.
On n'a pas non plus des pistes où on opère.
Nous devons donc pouvoir faire décélérer l'avion
d'environ 100 kilomètres à l'heure à zéro en une demi-seconde.
Et la façon dont nous faisons ça,
c'est en utilisant un fil qui suit cet avion lorsqu'il arrive,
avec une précision au centimètre.
Nous attrapons l'avion hors du ciel,
et puis nous le déposons doucement sur un coussin.
C'est en gros la combinaison d'un porte-avions
et d'un château gonflable.
(Rires)
Alors laissez-moi vous montrer.
(Applaudissements)
C'est peut-être évident pour vous, pourquoi je clôture avec cette vidéo.
Je veux montrer les enfants et les adolescents
qui s'alignent sur la clôture tous les jours.
Ils acclament chaque lancement et chaque atterrissage.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Parfois, je me présente au centre de distribution tôt
à cause du décalage horaire.
J'arrive une heure avant l'ouverture.
Il y a des enfants sur la clôture ayant de bons sièges.
(Rires)
Et si on leur demande :
« Que pensez-vous des avions ? »,
ils répondent : « Oh, c'est une ambulance du ciel. »
Ils ont compris.
Je veux dire, plus que la plupart des adultes.
Donc, je demandais plus tôt :
qui va créer les entreprises de l'Afrique utilisant les technologies de rupture
dans les dix ans à venir ?
En fin de compte, ça va être ces enfants.
Ce sont les ingénieurs du Rwanda et de l'Afrique.
Ils sont les ingénieurs de notre avenir commun.
Mais la seule façon de construire cet avenir est de réaliser
que les entreprises en pleine mutation peuvent évoluer en Afrique,
et cette technologie de rupture peut commencer ici en premier lieu.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)